hey guys and welcome to new series of
city skylines now well in the background
in the time-lapse I'm just laying down
the bare bones of the road layout of the
future city I would just like to have a
small introduction to explain what I'd
like to do with this city and what I'm
aiming for basically I'm gonna make a
modern Dutch style sub urban city which
if you have no idea what I'm talking
about because you look from the
Netherlands I'll explain that in a bit
but it's basically something which I
have always wanted to make in a city
building game it never really caught you
and I think City skylines is the first
game of such a scale which actually
allows you to possibly build touch style
cities and the reason why I would really
like to do so is well probably a bit of
Dutch pride as well because I'm from
Holland myself but also it's something
which I feel like is very interesting
and also fun to make and fun to look at
as well it's very different from the
American grid like more spread-out way
of building cities and which if you're
not from the Netherlands and you have no
idea what I'm talking about right now
basically the Netherlands has a very
high population density I believe even
higher than Japan and also then add
people in the Netherlands like to talk
about everything a couple thousand years
before actually doing it and thanks to
that awesome combination of cultural
things many many of the neighborhoods in
cities over here are pre-planned
in many years ahead and once all the
road designs and house designs are all
carefully laid out they actually start
building them in one go and everybody
kind of enters them in one go as well
but as the results you also kind of get
very funnily structured neighborhoods
and it's very much in a different way
from how American cities look and it's
something which I am a big fan of
actually well as much as you can be a
fan of city structures I suppose and
it's something which I actually wanted
to try in a game as well now I do have
to say actually sort of expected people
to have done this before so I looked up
some some while people who have done
this before to check out on tips on how
to make a Dutch style city but I was
pretty surprised that I couldn't really
find anything despite the large amount
of assets and
maps that are in the workshop that have
a Dutch theme to them I couldn't really
find any Dutch style cities there was
just one on the workshop that I found
but it wasn't entirely what I'm looking
for so I actually had to run a couple of
tests cities to get the hang of it kind
of experiment with it and finally at
some point I felt confident enough that
I could actually start in this series
and that's where we are right now and
that's pretty much when I'm recording
this video so basically what is going to
make this so much different from other
cities I believe is that well the bare
bones are definitely in the road layouts
but it's definitely going to be in the
houses as well and loads of row houses
and different City planning aspects but
that should be a lot clearer when we
actually get to it but it's basically a
couple of things to keep in mind when it
comes to Dutch road layouts is dance one
thing which they kind of like to do is
split up different roads in kind of ways
you've got two main types at least I
kind of look at it this way this
probably not a very correct way of
looking at it but you've got the roads
which are kind of used to transport
people such as highways or intercity
roads or those large four-lane roads
that run through the middle of your city
and then you've got the smaller Road
which house is actually located right
next to and usually in the Netherlands
and houses are not really located next
to these transport type roads but rather
these strands per type roads are
actually used to get to little parts of
the city which just have these smaller
type roads with houses next to them and
the trick with many of these cities is
that they have a road layout which means
that you can use the transport roads to
get to for example the other side of the
city or from one neighborhood to another
one but all the little smaller roads
which houses a net located next to I do
have barely any entrances to get there
or are very squiggly and pretty much
like mazes with dead ends everywhere
which ultimately is a very bad thing if
you are a car user and you want to get
somewhere which people like to complain
about but it's actually from a traffic
standpoint it works pretty well since
you get the all of the roads which
people live next to are much more quiet
and you can
have all the traffic around the roads
where you want it and not have any
houses attached to it either which is
also something that should become a lot
clearer as we kind of go through with
the video and the result of this is also
and you can kind of see right here I'm
laying down the road which will just be
used for people to get to their house
and move around there but you can't
actually use these roads to get anywhere
else as you as you can see that kind of
form their own little blocks which is
one or two entrances maybe three
sometimes and this really means you
can't cut off any routes you just have
to use these either four-lane roads or
one lane road with the roundabouts that
you can see there to get somewhere else
which is actually quite cool because you
can also mess a lot with different
shapes of neighborhoods have curved
roads and have some interesting
geometrical things actually going on
with your road patterns which is
something that I would like to
experiment with a bit more in the future
you'll see that in the first couple of
episodes there's actually a lot of
straightness still to the roads as I was
still trying to kind of make it right
with the row houses especially since
they work best and in the most easy way
of your roads are straights but I would
like to miss a bit work more with shapes
in the future but you can also you can
already kind of see that you start
having these very curvy transmit roads
and in the middle of that you kind of
get these island blocks of smaller roads
with with which you'll have the houses
and it's actually a lot of fun to mess
with those shapes what you also see is
that there are going to be roundabouts
everywhere and it's gonna arguably be an
unrealistic amount of roundabouts but I
really wanted to try to get every single
place where these most important roads
with a lot of traffic are going to meet
up to let those just be roundabouts it's
something which you see a lot in the
Netherlands and even coming from a City
skylines perspective within the game
it's just better to have roundabouts for
traffic flow and I just hate traffic
lights anyway so that should be fine
eventually too and yeah that's pretty
much my sort of plan with this though I
do have to say I didn't really plan out
these roads too much I just kind of had
this couple of empty maps
to have a bit of practice with drawing
the roads but other than that it's
really just drawing them wherever I feel
like sometimes it didn't really work out
too well like very conveniently over
here actually where I just figured in
the end I just built them straight
because it was much easier and I was
kind of failing with an entire structure
that I had over there before but usually
it does go pretty smoothly and I don't
really have too many issues with it I do
have to say this has already been seven
minutes of me just drawing roads it
actually was more I already had to cut
off a bit of it I'll only get into
really placing down and zoning places
it's ten minutes into the video I really
wanted to make sure that I get the road
layouts done in the right way before I
moved on and to be very honest this is
going to be quite characteristic of the
entire series I believe since much of
the focus will be on actually creating a
realistic Dutch style city and other
things won't we won't really be quite as
important and really the theme doesn't
really allow me to be too creative and
fantasizing about different types of
scenery and placing rocks and dense
forests and foliage and parks everywhere
since realistically it doesn't really
happen so not too much particular things
are going to happen when it comes to
that and much of my focus is going to be
on getting the road layouts done right
and seeing what sorts of buildings I can
add here in there and because that's
also something which I find very
interesting you get a very homogeneous
sort of array of houses in every little
area the same row houses often in a
couple of streets and it's going to be
even more so in this game since I
couldn't really find too many row house
sets
I actually were a couple that I don't
really like but they crush my game so I
kind of can use them which was really
annoying because now I only have two
different row house sets that I can use
but the thing is you can also kind of
mess with the types of houses that you
place down usually if you're building a
american-style city you just block down
the houses and kind of just let them
grow from there and see what grows but
since the houses are planned as well as
the roads you kind of want to use the
the same houses everywhere and also plan
your apartment blocks or other service
structures exactly at certain points
rather than just zoning an area and
letting letting the people in the game
go loose which is actually quite
interesting as well even though it was
more time-consuming I do have to add
about this little place where I just ant
this tower and that supermarkets that
was quite honestly just one spot where I
wanted to just drop a couple of services
I needed to get those services in and I
just figured that would be the best
place for now but I'm definitely going
to move that in the future I'm sort of
planning that area to be a campus and
you'll see that with the other services
at the moment as well my water
production things are really in the
middle of nowhere and very random and
it's things like that that I would like
to focus on at a later stage so right
now the most important services like
energy water but also the university are
really just there so that there's
somewhere but I'm going to move them
later on and actually get some realistic
things for them at some point in time
but for now it's just placeholders for
that and I really wanted to get make
sure that I got the city itself done and
this is pretty much where I started to
get that you can kind of see these row
houses develop over here with I would
always say these three typical red roofs
that you find everywhere I do really
have to find I thank the workshop
creators of these assets by the way
especially of the Dutch brohamer scent
which you can find there without that
Dutch row house set it would have been
nearly impossible to actually make this
work so thank you so much because it is
very important that I actually have that
look going on there and then over here I
wanted to just blend a couple of
appointment flats especially since that
Road a kind of functions as the entrance
row toward the city which most people
are going to use and you often find that
the appointment books is sort of located
next to that
and I wanted to get that in there as
well because it's something that you do
often find even within the areas that
are otherwise just small houses you have
a couple of flats here and there and I
kind of wanted to have that in here as
well and some simple parts as well
though I'll actually make the parks look
a lot better in later episodes for now
the main focus is just on making it look
like sort of like it is going to be
eventually and planning out certain
things but not really perfecting them
yet and not adding too much detail
although I did want to add a couple of
shrubs and trees to these roads to make
sure that that already looks the way I
want it to look in the final stages and
that's pretty much what I kind of wanted
to do over here also next to this
transport road over here I actually do
have a couple of not row houses that are
just just randomly there that's
something which you'll probably see
returning quite a bit more in the series
since and well realistically not really
an everything in the Netherlands is
completely planned outs especially the
older parts of the cities are much more
just like pretty much the rest of an
Arabian City it's really just that the
newer neighborhoods are very much
planned out but here and there you still
find some roads with standalone houses
and just not row houses which is the
thing that you do still see which is
kind of a shame that I couldn't really
find any Dutch detached houses because I
would like to really get that in there
as well and that's something which I do
have to say as much as I want to come
close to a Dutch style city sometimes
just in-game limitations or a lack of
assets just don't allow it so it's
definitely going to be inspired by Dutch
cities and I'm going to try to imitate
it but it won't be a 100% carbon copy of
Dutch city design which partly I do like
to have a bit of freedom especially when
it comes to doing the harder things
which I don't really know too much about
since quite honestly in order to
actually pull this off I had to look at
a lot of things in Google Maps I spent a
lot of time actually on Google Maps
looking at things and as much as it's
fun to do so
and trying to copy things from real life
I sometimes it just doesn't really work
or it's really hard to make it work and
sometimes too I just want to come up
with my own things and fantasize a bit
about things so it's I'm gonna take a
little bit of leeway anyway but I'm
gonna try to make this quite close
really and what I have right now should
be a pretty good representation of where
I want to go for with the rest of the
city I'll be it with different road
layouts throughout the rest of the city
as well some more flat blocks and of
course some different types of buildings
and different types of parks and things
like that as well but so far this is
actually about it for the time-lapse
part I do still have a little part that
I recorded earlier actually I'm with
life commentary about what I did in the
game so I actually jump to that for a
second
so I wanted to provide a quick little
overview of what it currently looks like
and what sort of direction I want to
head into and now keep in mind this is
actually recorded way before I actually
do the commentary because I want to get
a number of time lapses going before
actually put this on YouTube because I
might just give up on this series like
I'd a bit I like I did before way too
many times but yeah why I kind of want
to head into and still don't know what
exactly it's gonna be like is the same
idea as what it currently has it's it's
a very Dutch road system in a sense that
it really divides you go from the
highway into a slightly smaller Road
which is a bit like a national road
really which already kind of has this
dog bone over here which divides it over
for different directions and then you
get into the roundabouts and this is
gonna be a complete roundabout fest in
the real Dutch style of building cities
really where you get these divisions
into somewhat smaller roads and from
those you go and into the actual places
where people live so you kind of really
branch off and there aren't really too
many connections like for instance this
entire block of houses only has this one
little road to connect it to the rest of
the world and that road kind of needs to
go all the way over there to actually
make it to the highway and that should
at least keep the traffic decent but
really the first and foremost most
important thought that went into this
entire city is that I want to make it as
Dutch looking as
sport it's not really too great there's
a number of things which I'm not too
happy about like the fact that all of
these roads are asphalt roads and in the
Netherlands you wouldn't have that you
would have the brick paving roads inside
the actual living areas small details
like that that I can't really get in and
also these are very old-fashioned Dutch
houses but they're on a much more newer
style road layout which also kind of
doesn't make sense but it's the sort of
general feeling which I'm going for and
kind of want to go through with the
entire series so yeah this will also be
somewhere off the and the newer housing
really and this little place over here
should be the downtown eventually and
that's pretty much what I'm gonna do so
thanks for watching and I'll see if I
can actually get some good work done and
exit